[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es Y estos son los titulares en
túnez tras las declaraciones del
presidente
contra la presencia de migrantes
subsaharianos en el país las agresiones
y los actos racistas contra las personas
negras se intensifican varios países de
África occidental han decidido repatriar
a sus ciudadanos mientras que muchos
otros migrantes se encuentran en una
situación extremadamente precaria el
presidente francés Emmanuel Mako ha
finalizado su viaje de cuatro días por
África Central una gira para intentar
renovar las relaciones con un continente
en el que Francia está perdiendo terreno
el Fest Paco el festival de cine para
africano más importante del mundo ha
concluido en la capital burkinesa la
edición de este año se celebró en un
clima relativamente tenso debido sobre
todo a la crisis de seguridad que
atraviesa burkina faso
en túnez la crisis continúa tras los
comentarios del presidente Kaiser sobre
la presencia de los migrantes
subsaharianos en este país del norte de
África recordemos que el jefe de estado
declaró el 21 de febrero su voluntad de
tomar medidas contra los migrantes
alegando que su presencia forma parte de
un complot para según sus propias
palabras ennegrecer túnez y alejarla de
su identidad árabe musulmana a partir de
estas declaraciones los ataques
violentos y los actos de racismo contra
migrantes y personas negras no han
dejado de multiplicarse mientras las
embajadas de varios países como Guinea o
Costa de Marfil empiezan a repatriar a
sus ciudadanos muchos migrantes siguen
atrapados en situaciones precarias y
inseguras
cambiamos su nombre para preservar su
seguridad Jessica no ha salido de casa
desde que fue agredida el lunes 27 de
febrero fue apuñalada en el pecho y
golpeada en plena calle por una banda de
seis jóvenes tunecinos
[Música]
de nuevo
de refugiada desde su llegada de Camerún
ha sido víctima de racismo en la calle
pero nunca de agresiones físicas
Laura de Costa de Marfil ha decidido
marcharse Tiene que dejar su casa lo
antes posible a petición del propietario
no tiene ni contrato de alquiler ni
tarjeta de residencia documentos muy
difíciles de obtener en túnez para los
migrantes está esperando una respuesta
en su embajada para poder estar en los
vuelos de repatriación
[Música]
se ve muy difícil
muchos viven en la calle estos migrantes
originarios de Guinea y Sierra Leona se
han instalado frente a la sede de una
ong internacional la mayoría vinieron en
busca de Refugio tras haber sido
Víctimas de la violencia pero aquí sus
condiciones de vida siguen siendo muy
precarias como las de Mohamed de 19 años
ven te enseñaré donde duermo duermo aquí
con mis tres hermanos
originario de Guinea vino a trabajar y a
ganar dinero para ir a Europa
no puedo volver Porque cuando pienso en
todo el dinero que se gastaron mis
padres para que llegara atunes me duela
el corazón es duro pero hay que ser
valiente
todos los días asociaciones y ciudadanos
tunecinos les llevan comida y asistencia
médica ahora decenas de ellos viven así
a la espera de que la situación mejore
el presidente francés Emmanuel finalizó
una gira por cuatro países de África
Central la República democrática del
Congo gabón Angola y la República del
Congo su propósito declarado era por un
lado afirmar su voluntad de entablar una
nueva relación con el continente donde
el sentimiento antifrancés no deja de
crecer y por el otro reforzar los trazos
económicos en un marco decreciente
influencia china sobre todo en
dependencia financiera y rusa con
presencia militar en aumento y un
acercamiento político en pleno contexto
de la guerra en Ucrania
el objetivo era un restablecimiento de
las relaciones entre Francia y el
continente africano la gira número 18 de
Manuel macron por África comenzó en
gabón antes de llevarlo a Angola luego a
República del Congo y finalmente a
República democrática del Congo un
recorrido durante el cual el jefe de
estado intentó restaurar la imagen de su
país que está perdiendo terreno frente a
Rusia China India y Turquía
si estoy hoy aquí con el placer de
encontrarme de nuevo con ustedes es
precisamente para construir una
asociación equilibrada sobre los temas
del clima y de la biodiversidad sobre
los temas económicos e industriales
etcétera para defender nuestros
intereses para llevar causas comunes en
gabón antigua Colonia francófona recién
incorporada a la common weld macron
habló del clima de la defensa de los
bosques tropicales y proclamó el fin de
la prensa frick término usado para
denotar la relación
idoneal entre Francia y sus antiguas
colonias
gabón como en todas partes Francia es un
interlocutor neutral que habla con todo
el mundo y cuyo papel es no interferir
en los plazos políticos internos
la gira de macron fue una oportunidad
para iniciar nuevas asociaciones
económicas con el continente la razón es
que Francia ha visto reducida su cuota
de Mercado en un 4% en África mientras
que china se sitúa en el 18%. en Angola
país luzófono de 34 millones de
habitantes la agenda fue principalmente
económica con el lanzamiento de una
colaboración en agricultura y
agroalimentación en la República
democrática del Congo donde la cuestión
del conflicto en el este del país con
Los Rebeldes del m-23 tensa las
relaciones entre la República
democrática el Congo y Ruanda el
presidente congoleño Felix chisequedy
animó a macron en un momento de tensión
entre ambos a forjar una nueva era en
las relaciones entre Francia y África
miren los de otra manera respetándonos
como verdaderos socios y no siempre con
una mirada paternalista y con la idea de
saber siempre lo que es mejor para
nosotros
es también para evitar que Rusia
prospere en África por lo que Francia
pretende renovar sus lazos políticos
económicos y de seguridad con algunos
países del continente queda por ver si
el cambio de estrategia del gobierno
francés permitirá al país galo recuperar
su lugar en la competición de grandes
potencias que tiene lugar actualmente en
África
en Nigeria pese a la movilización de los
jóvenes a favor de una alternativa a la
clase política tradicional
volatinum de 70 años y candidato del
partido de todos los progresistas la
formación de la mayoría saliente ha
ganado las elecciones presidenciales el
presidente electo hereda una nación
inmersa en la inseguridad creciente con
ataques constantes de bandas criminales
y grupos yihadistas además deberá
combatir una inflación sin precedentes y
un elevado desempleo hablamos con nandio
basi especialista de Nigeria en el
International crysis Group sobre lo que
le espera en Nigeria con la elección de
bolatú
promete Que hará las cosas con más vigor
que las hará de otra manera pero hay
dudas al respecto
de todos los progresistas el partido
gobernante Durante los últimos ocho años
y entonces la gente se pregunta por qué
no habría hecho cosas para mejorar la
situación en los últimos años y esperar
hasta ahora Así que hay muchas dudas
sobre Qué puede hacer exactamente de
forma diferente
también hay cuestiones sobre su edad y
su falta de vigor en un caso en el que
los problemas del país están aumentando
en gran medida por lo que no hay mucho
entusiasmo sobre lo que puede hacer
pero sí que tiene el reto de hacer algo
no solo sobre la economía y no solo
sobre la seguridad sino también sobre la
reconciliación del país que está tan
fracturada ahora tan polarizado y el
presidente tendrá la primera tarea de
intentar reunir a la gente de nuevo para
creer en una causa común como país
pez Paco así se llama el festival más
importante de cine panafricano
organizado en burkina faso desde 1972
durante una semana la capital guagadugo
se ilumina para acoger a miles de
aficionados y profesionales del cine
panafricano para celebrar El séptimo
arte nuestra enviada especial María nos
hace un recuento de la edición número 28
de este destacado evento cultural a
pesar de la inseguridad más de 10.000
extranjeros llegaron a iwagadugo capital
de
hoy edición del festejo durante una
semana se proyectaron 1200 películas en
los cines de guagadugo Y fue el tunecino
Joseph quien recibió
el premio más prestigioso del fespaco
por su película
fue concedido a la director burguesa
por su película siga mientras que la
keniana Ángela
guaimé gañó el etano de bronce la
ceremonia de clausura estuvo marcado por
la presencia del presidente de la
transición Ibrahim que fue aclamado por
el público una ceremonia que puso que
puso fin a una semana de festival y de
proyección la próxima edición del lugar
durante dentro de dos años en febrero de
esta edición del fespaco se llevó a cabo
en un contexto marcado por la llegada al
poder de una junta militar Y como lo
acaba de mencionar nuestra Indiana
especial por la multiplicación de
atentados yadistas mientras burkina faso
trata de atravesar este periodo de
violencia el fespaco se ha convertido en
una burbuja de alegría el siguiente es
un reportaje de Marian coné
en el contexto del fespaco los turistas
vienen a visitar este lugar emblemático
situado a 40 minutos de la capital
esto da Esperanza un sector cuyas cifras
de visitantes no hacen más que disminuir
hemos notado un promedio de llegadas de
turistas pero el país no se resume a su
crisis de seguridad también tenemos una
cultura un sector del turismo
desarrollado
además de las visitas turísticas en la
noche el Fest Paco organiza proyecciones
itinerantes como en el barrio de camboza
desde donde los camiones cargados de
soldados se dirigen al norte para luchar
contra los y aristas A sus 30 años suele
desear enrolarse voluntariamente en el
ejército pero mientras esperaba tomar
una decisión viene a este cine al aire
libre para distraersea
por la noche viendo este tipo de
películas puedes relajarte y olvidar tus
preocupaciones hasta el punto de poder
dormir Mejor
vamos a ver en 2016 este bar fue testigo
del primer atantado y Arista en la
capital esta semana es la primera vez en
7 años que se organiza un evento de este
magnitud en esta calle
hacía mucho tiempo que no podíamos
divertirnos en esta calle gracias al
fespaco con la cena que hay veo que Los
Bukis pueden divertirse un poco digo un
poco porque no hay verdadera alegría con
la situación del país
a pesar de los centenas de turistas que
llegaron en más de 50 años de existencia
nunca antes una edición del fespago
había atraído tan pocas personas en el
país de los hombres íntegros
[Música]
así cerramos esta edición de África 7
días Si desean hacer comentarios o
preguntas envíenlos en la cuenta Twitter
que aparece en pantalla Mientras tanto
la actualidad internacional continúa en
France 24
[Música]